Trump leading the pack in the Republican
primary he's also leading Joe Biden by a
lot and this poll is shocking
according to the reaction to it and
according to some of the headlines but
it shouldn't be all that shocking if
you've been following the Washington
Post ABC Poll for the past number of
months so head to head
right now in a hypothetical 2024 matchup
Trump has 51 support to Joe Biden's 42
support
that's pretty big up nine points on
Biden
that this is good for Trump because he's
now up three points since the last ABC
Washington Post poll in February and
Biden is down by two points but those
shifts taken individually for the
candidates are actually not
statistically significant and even back
in February Trump was leading Biden
according to this poll from a liberal
Outlet there's even less change since
May the ABC post did the poll in May and
in may they had the race at 49.42 Trump
over Biden